hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Thomas Aquinas in Article 2 of question
46 of the first of the second part of so
Mateo logia is grappling with some
really fundamental moral questions
regarding the emotion of anger and it's
not asking is anger as such good or bad
he'll discuss that in other questions
and and articles but he's thinking about
the object the objectum what it is that
anger is you could say aiming at but
also oriented by whether that is good or
bad or if you like good or evil and I do
have to point out you notice that I
often use the black Friars translation
this is a case where the black Friars
because of the particular translator
could lead you a little bit astray
because they title this is the object of
anger agreeable
or disagreeable which makes it sound
more or less about being Pleasant or
unpleasant or painful when really it's
very very straightforward the ques the
the article is
whether the object of anger sit bonum
good good just good per se uh Vel malam
bad or evil there's no qualification of
agreeable or disagreeable painful or
pleasurable although that will come up a
little bit in the discussion as kind of
an adjunct here we're actually talking
about these basic modalities is it good
is it bad
and this is also a very interesting
article
in the way that it's structured uh
usually what Thomas likes to do is bring
up three possible arguments and then
there's the on the contrary and you'll
bring up you know like one possible
counter argument then he'll tell you his
thing and then he'll talk about the
initial arguments and his replies to
these objections right
in this case he actually says the at the
end the difficulties have been duly
answered potent responsio ad objecta in
in the Latin so he's not actually going
to address them individually the other
thing that's kind of unusual he's going
to bring up two different
counter positions so the first one he
says that um
seems that the object of anger is bad
why Gregory of Nisa somebody who talks a
lot about anger says that anger is as it
were the armor bearer of Desire an armor
Bearer is somebody who carries your
armor and helps you out right and it's
the armored bearer of Desire Con
kupascantia in the sense that it attacks
whatever would frustrate desire so
whatever is going to put up quite
literally in the Latin an impedimentum a
a block an impediment in your way
whatever frustrates that that's what
anger turns against and so anger is
looking at that as something that is bad
so that tells us that you know the uh
the answer is it's something
disagreeable or bad the second one
anger and hatred have a common effect
they produce the same thing and that
both seek what to injure another person
in fere literally to impose or carry on
to no commentum alteri so nokare is to
to hurt or to injure another person what
is it that anger and hatred both want
the same thing right they just want it
in rather different ways so what this
means is that since the object of hatred
is the bad right it wants to impose
something bad well then the same must be
true of anger okay so now we've got two
things arguing for the object of anger
being bad the third one has to do with
what anger is produced by he says
sadness or pain you know tristia is the
Latin and that's what Thomas uses
typically the the sources that he is
bring bringing up would use you know
dolor pain or in Greek Lupe so you know
anger in Aristotle's definition which
Thomas you know relies upon is uh caused
by pain it is with pain right but he's
going to say sadness I think that works
there's like a whole range of emotion
that is involved with anger so since it
rises from sadness
um and since the object of sadness is
bad right you're not sad about good
things you're sad about bad things
anger its object must be bad as well so
now we've got three Arguments for anger
having a a you know Badness modem as its
object what about goodness
so here we get to other aspects of anger
and he says Augustine says anger craves
Revenge vindicta right so Vindication is
another way of putting this that's what
anger is oriented towards in the Greek
timoracis uh you know retribution or
event revenge or ways we can translate
this so Thomas says the desire for
Revenge
is now here's something interesting is
not just for something agreeable it is
for something good
why why is Thomas endorsing Revenge
seeking he says that
um it's you know a revenge is a matter
of justice so insofar as uh Vindication
the you know retribution that anger is
aiming at is viewed as just whether
wrongly or rightly it is viewed as a
good thing by the person who is trying
to impose it the person who is angry and
acting on that so he says the hence the
object of anger is the good
the Thomas will call this in other
places the difficult good right the good
that requires us to protect it or
contend in order to achieve it
um another argument he says hope always
accompanies anger
um you know and also anger is gratifying
so here's where we see delect patio
being brought up and that could be also
translated as Delight or pleasure so
anger involves these things at least
when you actually attain the Vindication
that you're aiming at but it can also be
delightful to think about the hope and
so he says sense anger involves these
the object of anger is agreeable
now what do we make of all of this
um
this is when Thomas thinks we need to
analyze the way anger works and compare
it to other emotions and we do that by
starting with some really basic points
about how the emotions and the we could
call them movements the motus the
reactions of the appetite of uh you know
part of ourselves how that actually
works so Thomas is going to say an
appetite of reaction a motus a movement
literally
um now it's translated here presupposes
but the Latin is actually
sequitur
so you know that means to follow so it
follows a cognitive or perceptual act
apprehensive right so apprehensiva could
be including the cognitive the
specifically thoughtful part right we
have Angry thoughts oh that person
injured me let me go get revenge it
could also involve perception and
remember that in Aristotle's definition
of anger way back in ancient Greece
which Thomas is familiar with from the
rhetoric anger involves perception right
actually in two different ways so he
goes out and he says in this act of
apprehending we can have two different
kinds of objects there can be an in
complex and the Latin there literally is
in complexity
in complexity and he says for example
when we understand
what a human being is so when we're
thinking about human nature human beings
and we are grasping that that's an
incomplex object I mean is it really we
could debate that right because human
nature is kind of complicated but we can
also have a complex object and what does
he mean there things have been literally
folded together so grasping that a human
being is white right so he says in both
of these ways there can be an appetite
of
reaction that follows this complex or
incomplex cognitive or perceptual act
right so the appetite of reaction
literally reaching out to something used
in a generic sense
can be to the good or to the bad to what
we grasp not just cognitively but
affectively as good or bad what we what
we feel to be good or bad and so he says
um
what happens in these cases well let's
think about different emotions when the
object is simple and incomplex the
appetite simply pursues or clings to
what is agreeable and shrinks from what
is disagreeable and he's using a lot of
different uh terms here that are
translated with with synonyms basically
it tries to avoid or push away or flee
from uh take I mean we could actually
play off of the word here refugre in
Latin to take refuge from right to say
get out of here get get this away from
me
or it can cleave to cling to in higher
today or aim at you know strive for the
the good depending on how it perceives
it so what are examples of these
emotions he says reactions of this sort
movements of these sort are hope space
you know delight and sadness and others
and so on right uh and aliyahui's Modi
and others of this sort
so that's when it's simple what if it's
complex what if we're grasping something
complex he says when the object is
complex the appetite is concerned with
something that is good or bad
uh that is in something else so I like
you know I I love I have this good warm
fuzzy feeling towards you as an
intelligent person right there's there's
a complex thing there there's
intelligent and then there's the you and
if I'm loving you I love both of these
aspects of you if I'm like well you know
I hate your guts because you are an
abusive person you're always being mean
to me right the abusiveness is the one
part and then the you is that the
abusiveness you could say is in or comes
from is the the other part and both of
them are bad right and so I react in
that way and so he says love and hatred
are clear examples of this right when we
love someone we want now notice what he
says here he's kind of Shifting things a
little bit it's not just I'm reacting to
what's in the purse person we actually
want something good for that person
I love my you know child I want them to
have a good school experience right I
hate my child I want them to have a bad
school experience right and I want
something bad for them and so he says
there's something like this in anger
but it works differently at anger right
how so well this is where we get to the
complex of the complex he says when a
person is angered they seek to avenge
themselves on another person so they're
aiming at
vindicta vindicacio
Vindication retribution they want that
on that other person and so they are
oriented both towards that person and
towards the Vindication that they're
seeking so he says anger reacts in two
directions
towards the Vindication the Revenge
right which it desires and hopes for
appetite uh you know as what as
something good
under the he says secret quota bonum as
a certain kind of good right and he says
and it takes some Delight in that so
there's both the aspect of like good per
se or good in this way and then there's
the pleasant so that's one side of anger
the the Revenge part Yay good I like
that I'm seeking that then there's the
second part aimed at and now notice the
terminology that he uses here he says it
also aims
um at this you know the the person that
it's trying to get at Secret in contrary
at nokivum right so it's treating the
person as
somebody who opposes somebody who
contradicts or or up you know is against
you contrarian right your contrary you
don't mix with this and as harmful uh no
kivo somebody who is hurting you that
they that's how they made you angry in
the first place and in that respect they
are viewed as bad he doesn't say as
unpleasant in this case he just says
quote
Mali so they're being looked at as as
bad right so anger incorporates both of
these sides to it so what is its object
uh is it good is it bad well it's
actually both and it's both by the very
nature of anger and how it works
this Thomas says is very important
because it allows us to distinguish
anger and the way it works from Love and
hatred which are also kind of complex in
this way but are either all aimed at the
good or all aimed at the bad
so he says anger always has a two-fold
object whereas love and hatred may have
only one for example speaking of loving
or hating why getting away from a person
you love wine great you love wine you
have a warm fuzzy feeling to where you
hate wine you have a cold prickly
feeling towards it as we used to say
back in you know Elementary School and
positive and negative affective
reactions that's very simple
um when uh love is you know aimed at a
complex object both of the objects are
agreeable both what is loved and the
person for whom it's loved are viewed as
good right with hatred it's the opposite
both objects of hatred are bad and
hating a person you find them bad and
you wish them bad
anger has an agreeable object the
Revenge the Vindication that you're
seeking or a good object object that's
viewed as good and a bad object the
person by whom one has been injured and
on whom one seeks revenge and he he
closes with this very interesting
observation anger as an emotion as a
passio is made up in a sense is composed
of contrary emotions it is two different
drives we could say mixed in there
together right and he says this
composite
right so that is a very interesting
thing to say about anger one of the most
complex and often perplexing of the
human emotions to go back to the central
question what is the object of anger
it's both good and bad both of them
interconnect did with each other